recovery i'm talking about the possible
near future for america in our fight
against covid even as we are in the
middle of a battle against the omicron
variant more than 5.4 million americans
tested positive last week that is a new
record but take a look at this new york
city's numbers are dropping and dropping
fast in terms of both cases and
hospitalizations that's a big deal
because new york was one of the first
places hit hard by the variant and it
follows a similar trajectory in south
africa where omicron was first
discovered and as our deborah patta
shows us that is good news there that
could be a sign of better times ahead in
this country
after just eight weeks since the world
first heard about omicron discovered
here in south africa the country's wave
has dropped as sharply as it had risen
and there's been very little
interruption to people's lives
children remain in school
restaurants are busy and the city is
bustling
omicron quickly became the focus of
global anxiety infections spread here
with ferocious speed
within days south africa was the
epicenter of the disease and then well
not much at all
we've monitored the same covert woods
throughout the pandemic during the
omicron wave it's as if it's a
completely different hospital half empty
very few patients requiring oxygen and
the staff are under a lot less pressure
it was the complete opposite just six
months ago during the country's battle
with the delta variant then the same
hospital was overwhelmed you are a human
being before before you become a nurse
so seeing people dying like that is very
very hard
that was exhausted covered nurse justice
mangala speaking to us then this time
round he can count the deaths on one
hand i'm a little bit at ease
now that we have got this second line of
defense which is our
vaccine
it's the vaccine and previous infections
that have boosted south africa's
immunity to the virus explains
vaccinologist professor shabri ahmadi
and that has dramatically reduced severe
illness and death the omicron wave now
accounts for less than five percent
of all of the deaths that has occurred
due to covert 19 since the start of the
pandemic
marty believes that while there will
still be many more variants the acute
phase of the pandemic at least here in
south africa with its devastating death
toll could be over
i'm highly optimistic that we have
richard turning point as pandemic i
can't see us revisiting what we
experienced during the course of the
first three waves in south africa and in
fact i'm optimistic
in most other countries some high-income
countries have cautioned against relying
too much on the south african data but
scientists like professor mahdi battle
to understand their reluctance to learn
from the south african experience for
cbs morning's deborah patter
johannesburg
deborah powder thank you